e aí
e eu hoje busco meu equilíbrio porque
ele tem muito com a insanidade dos
extremos eu fui
e eu fui um skatista dos meus 10 aos 18
anos e um skatista que vivenciou muito
essa questão de sexo droga e rock and
roll e levei isso muito a sério muito a
sério mesmo isso não é só coisa de
música de filme não isso pode ser uma
prática de vida e ela é atrativa é uma
vida é bem atrativa eu cogitei se ele
skatista profissional participei de
alguns campeonatos mas antes que eu
pudesse me profissionalizar antes que eu
pudesse alçar voos maiores eu tive
questionamentos pessoais e com meus 17
anos aquilo que parecia o adolescente
rebelde sem causa questionando a sua
vida eu tive um despertar espiritual um
site em uma segunda-feira de manhã
tomando uma garrafa de vinho na praça
pensa segunda-feira de manhã tomando um
vinho na praça por isso que eu friso que
a questão ali era bem vivida 11
a rua se aproximou de mim de um amigo e
pediu para compartilhar da bebida e
compartilhar sua história conosco e ali
já já estava questionando que o meu
mundo era muito azul era o mundo muito
prazeroso muito gostoso de se viver será
que era só aquilo será que não haveria
um propósito de vida nas outras vidas ao
meu redor que eu poderia auxiliar e esse
morador de rua então foi o meu insight
espiritual foi o meu despertar
espiritual
bom então eu e esse esse meu amigo com
17 para 18 anos fundamos uma comunidade
de acolhimento e recuperação para
moradores de rua então eu fui
literalmente da água para o vinho mas ao
contrário né do vinho para a água
e eu por três anos vive como frei
franciscano os votos de castidade
a pobreza e obediência então de um
extremo ao outro da noite para o dia
eu e nessa vida eu tive algumas
percepções e hoje tento aplicar no meu
dia a dia percepções nos dois extremos
por isso que falo até importância dos
extremos e como tudo na vida está em
observar os detalhes e fazer desses
detalhes ferramentas para nossa
transformação interior
há um questionamento muito profundo e
construir junto com o senhor em situação
de rua foi essa questão de refletir
sobre o ontem o hoje eo amanhã e a frase
que concretiza tudo isso que traz com
palavras e sentimento ele dizia que a
gente construiu esse raciocínio
refletindo de forma mais ampla que a
vida na rua para quem vive nela e essa
vida na rua coloca o também a questão de
depressão de tristeza de ansiedade que
pode acontecer com qualquer um de nós é
muito mais do que uma simples condição
de vida vivenciada no presente
e ela é uma ocasião de remorso de coisas
que aconteceram ontem de coisas mal
resolvidas que aconteceram ontem falta
de vontade desse bem viver o hoje e
dificuldade de se esperar um amanhã
melhor então isso se aplica a cada um de
nós independente do nosso contexto
porque a situação das amarras do passado
nos impedindo de bem mirar o alvo do
futuro é algo que prejudica muito a
nossa saúde mental a nossa saúde mental
ela fica em dest quando a gente não tem
a ordem adequada do passado das
vivências no presente e o futuro é o
futuro pensado em demaseio gera
ansiedade e o passado é a enraizado
vivido com no presente ele gera
depressão ansiedade tristeza muitas as
pessoas esquecem de mirar o presente é
isso que a gente vai compartilhar aqui
um pouco nesse momento a
os detalhes do presente a riqueza do
momento presente eu me via nessa
situação então vivendo muito bem muito
feliz mas faltava algo eu fazia
faculdade de administração de empresa na
época e em certa manhã de acolhimento
duas pessoas me perguntaram aí eu eu
realizando o curativo e essas duas
pessoas me perguntaram henrique você é
enfermeiro foi não à tarde uma terceira
pessoa me perguntou rick se faz
enfermagem aí minha resposta mudou eu
não faço mas provavelmente semana que
vem eu comece e assim fez tranquei meu
curso administração de empresa comecei a
enfermagem e obtive a minha realização
profissional e ao que me ajudou muito
entender toda essa mudança foi a oração
da serenidade e essa oração da
serenidade pela apesar dela trazer esse
termo senhor esse senhor ele se aplica
independente do contexto religioso
cristo
ah ah ah lá big ben aquele poder
superior que cada um tem dentro de si
como referência de algo acima de nós e
ela diz o seguinte senhor concedei-me
serenidade necessária para aceitar as
coisas que não posso modificar coragem
para modificar aquelas que posso e
sabedoria para conhecer a diferença
entre elas e trabalhar serenidade
aceitação e coragem permite cada um de
nós transforma e aquilo que não nos faz
feliz no presente se tem algo que te
incomoda no presente tenha essa frase
essa oração como algo como mantra
pessoal para que você possa dar um passo
ou de transformação ou de aceitação o
que não podemos ficar inertes na nossas
infelicidades o que não podemos é deixar
que o nosso presente possa ser mal
vivido
e eu me formei enfermagem e descobri que
o meu prazer individual antes em cima do
skate se convertia ia no cuidar ao
próximo cuidando do outro eu cuidava da
minha alma do meu espírito e assim me
senti uma pessoa realizada em plenitude
então a minha coragem de transformar uma
profissão que eu provavelmente faria
carreira que provavelmente eu ganhar ia
mais que como enfermeiro que
provavelmente eu teria mais êxito deixei
tudo para trás abracei a enfermagem e
hoje vivo a enfermagem no sentido de
levar entusiasmo a as profissões
independente da sua carreira
independente da sua escolha ame o que
você faz ama e a sua escolha não for
possível sabedoria para raciocinar sobre
isso e coragem para mudar
é nesse contexto é meu primeiro emprego
pós-formado enfermagem foi no hospital
psiquiátrico eu era supervisor de
enfermagem hospital psiquiátrico e algo
que eu percebia muito era o
auto-abandono esse termo auto-abandono
eles refere a indivíduos em algum dado
momento da vida deixa de ter prazer nas
pequenas coisas do dia-a-dia deixa de
ter prazer em ter contato com outras
pessoas deixa de ter prazer em admirar
um bom livro um bom filme e assim
abandonando-se daquilo que lhe dá prazer
acaba entrando em estado de extrema
tristeza e aí vem as doenças mentais e a
gente sabe a ciência traz isso que o
nosso cérebro é movido por
neurotransmissores e nem sempre
medicamentos serão os responsáveis por
essa manutenção da saúde de caráter
preventivo e de caráter muito prático o
que nos dá a saúde mental
essa é a nossa boa vivência do dia a dia
né as nossas ações quando bem pontuados
quando prazerosas no dia a dia elas nos
permite a saúde mental e quem não quer
saúde mental segundo a organização
mundial de saúde 2020 será o ano de
maior incapacidade adoecimento mental da
história isso a gente já vê é quantas
pessoas tomam remédios tem dificuldades
em relação a ansiedade tristeza e
depressão então de caráter preventivo
cada um de nós podemos fazer muito por
nós vai fazer toda a diferença em
relação a nossa coragem dá o primeiro
passo
oi e esse primeiro passo é
principalmente aceitação da rotina
falando as rick a rotina é algo tão
chato tão maçante eu fico sempre
querendo fugir da minha rotina cuidado
com essa frase cuidado com essa
afirmação a rotina é aquilo que cada um
de nós iremos vivenciar por tempo
prolongado na nossa vida é aquilo que
mais vai se repetir e é aquilo que mais
vai se repetir porque não bem vivê-la
por que não bem praticá-la
e no hospital psiquiátrico em pessoas em
recuperação de doenças mentais graves eu
percebi que aquilo que era essencial
para que eles retornassem ao mundo real
retornasse ao seu encontro pessoal era
vivência da rotina tão importante como o
medicamento tomado no horário correto é
a vivência de uma rotina adequada nós
temos horário para comer para dormir
para relaxar para trabalhar né o nosso
dia tem 24 horas 24 horas é tempo para
caramba dá para fazer muita coisa e eu
ilustro isso de modo prático ano
retrasado eu vivenciei dois empregos
ainda vivem cio coordenador de
vigilância epidemiológica e educação em
saúde e fiz um mestrado acadêmico na
universidade federal vivendo as três
coisas ao mesmo tempo meus pais e alguns
amigos falar rick você vai pifar cuidado
será que você não tem que abandonar algo
deixar de lado o emprego
e deixar de lado o mestrado foi não vou
fazer tudo isso e vou tentar fazer da
melhor forma o que equilibra a nossa
rotina o que equilibra as nossas emoções
é a nossa própria reflexão a gente não
pode ter fatores externos influenciam
sobre isso nós devemos nos conhecer e
nos permitir acrescentar ou retirar
e eu no meu caso eu percebi que tava
legal fazer tudo isso mas eu precisava
de algo para mim relaxar ea o que me
relaxou muito nesse momento que parecia
conturbado foi a jardinagem em si jardim
lá em casa e jardim para amigos cheguei
a vender alguns arranjos nunca tinha
praticado jardinagem e me descobri com
esse contato com a natureza praticando
jardinagem no meu horário de almoço nos
meus fim de semana então eu não tirei
nada da minha rotina muito pelo
contrário eu acrescentei algo que ia
deixar se mais velho isso é individual
cada um vai descobrir aquilo que faz
feliz aquilo que que te atrai é para
deixar sua rotina mais leve e tem aquele
ditado quem planta flores atrai
borboleta em meia todo tá tudo isso que
parecia um caos que parecia um período
conturbado eu tive a grata surpresa de
conhecer a minha namorada aí no mestrado
encontrei aquela que me completasse que
me desse ali
a realização também emocional eu não
deixei esse detalhe passar desapercebido
nem se eu viver sim apenas refletindo
nossa eu tô fazendo muita coisa não
posso pensar em me envolver não posso
pensar em outra coisa não aceitar tudo
aquilo que tá acontecendo ao redor me
fez ter mais feliz é me deu uma
oportunidade de agregar mais naquilo que
eu estava desenvolvendo então isso foi
incrível isso foi fantástico me dá
excelentes reflexos até hoje comeu
mestrado consegui melhorar meu
posicionamento profissional na educação
e saúde continuo como gerente de
vigilância epidemiológica e como gerente
de vigilância epidemiológica agora
falando de algo atual uma grande
preocupação minha
e aí o pessoal pergunta a ric qual a
notificação que mais te assusta quando
chega na vigilância tecnológica é o
vírus respiratório vindo aí da china a
novidade assusta mas nem tanto quanto a
constância de notificações de violência
autoprovocada nos últimos cinco anos em
lavras e região um aumento de oitenta
por cento nessas notificações pessoas
que tentam contra a própria vida pessoas
que não estão felizes com as suas
rotinas e tentam contra a própria filha
e isso é muito grave e os precisa ser
modificado isso pode ser modificado com
a reflexão individual com exemplo
individual né e com a mensagem que a
gente pode levar daqui adiante
bom e você uma reflexão pessoal qual a
importância que você atribui as pequenas
coisas do dia-a-dia será que a gente tem
dado a devida notoriedade aos pequenos
detalhes do dia a dia eu volto aqui no
caso de acolhimento de uma pessoa em
situação de rua era o senhor que perdeu
tudo o senhor não na verdade eu tinha 42
anos mas tinha aparência de um senhor de
70 que ele ficou paraplégico por
fraqueza estava com uma broncopneumonia
muito intensa correndo risco de ficar
cego e foi abandonado pela família e
esse senhor vivenciou muito intensamente
tudo de errado na vida aprontou muito
ele foi abandonado no hospital nós
promovemos acolhimento
e levamos ele para casa e ele começou a
melhorar começou a dar sinais de
melhoria física e principalmente de
melhoria emocional ele começou a sorrir
e em certa manhã ele me chamou rick me
ajuda a tomar banho ajudei ele tomar
banho ele pediu um café da manhã daí o
café da manhã para ele ele pediu uma
roupa quente não é essa roupa quente
para ele e pediu para deitar cobriu aí
ele olhou bem no fundo dos meus olhos e
disse que eu te agradeço por tudo que
você fez os meus maiores medos era
morrer com fome frio sozinho e sujo e
nada disso está acontecendo apertou
minha mão fechou os olhos e partiu
é então isto isso é muito forte isso
marca muita a minha trajetória e me fez
dá mais importante ainda aos pequenos
detalhes será que você tá tendo prazer
quando tem oportunidade de beber uma
xícara de café será que você tá dando o
devido valor quando você tem sua cama
quente para deitar será que você tá
vivenciando bem esses pequenos detalhes
e fazendo assim que eu quis eu rotina
venha ser um pouco mais leve observe os
detalhes tão vendo essa árvore florida
aqui é uma macieira ao longo de toda a
todos os slides
e eu mostrei essa evolução aqui ó
se alguém percebeu a semente a evolução
a planta sendo determinada sinceramente
eu acho que poucos é isso a gente está
falando de uma apresentação de slides
mas isso aqui se aplica a vida né os
detalhes estão aí ao nosso redor estão
aí observados a cada um de nós será que
nós estamos fazendo a nossa parte de
acolhê-los de bem observá-los fica a
reflexão individual e que a gente passa
a ter um olhar mais sensível a tudo que
está ao nosso redor daqui olhando aquilo
que está ao nosso redor a gente possa
nos conhecer um pouco melhor bem início
hoje ao efeito borboleta dentro de você
de tudo aquilo que for discutido aqui
hoje que for compartilhado leve adiante
é isso que a gente deseja esse objetivo
do evento é o efeito borboleta ele não
pode ocorrer individualmente o efeito
borboleta ele fala de continuidade né
então isto é incrível e estabeleça
raízes e será auxílio para o
desenvolvimento do outro o seu
testemunho a sua vontade de viver
o ideal próximo francisco de assis tinha
uma frase que dizia para os seus
seguidores vão e anunciem a verdade
anuncio bem viver se for preciso fale
então o nosso exemplo é que nos motiva é
que nos transforma e que pode
transformar o outro eu desejo a todos
uma feliz rotina não tenham medo dela
ela é a constância que nos garante ser
pessoas melhores que nos permite que o
amanhã possa ser melhor que hoje não
faça da sua vida um testemunho e viva
bem obrigado a
[Aplausos]